CBS news political correspondent ed
O'Keefe joins us now for more on all of
this and let's start with the shutdown
yeah we were it was just about to get
really ugly at the airports we've got a
three week reprieve now is there any
evidence that a compromise can actually
be reached on border security in that
time well look the hostages have been
released but the standoff continues for
three more weeks yeah and I think you
know the thought that they are somehow
going to in three weeks settle something
that's roiled Washington this entire
century I think is it would be pretty
remarkable yeah and so we may very well
be back at this point in three weeks or
they may present him with a bunch of
options and say look we'll spend 5.7
billion dollars it's just we don't want
to spend it on
a physical wall from sea to shining sea
you know let's let's put together a
package with drones and with some
fencing and with more personnel and an
understanding that this ultimately does
help fortify the border and allow you to
say that you fought for this and in some
places there'll be no physical barriers
the president's still floating this idea
of a national emergency how likely is he
to make good on that threat well he says
he wants to do that but remember he
didn't do it and right I think part of
the reason he didn't do it is because
look at the numbers we had a CBS News
poll out earlier this month that showed
that a majority of Americans didn't like
the idea of doing that and and within
you know hours of that poll surfacing
suddenly the talk about a national
emergency subsided so he can threaten
that but the numbers are there and they
would probably still be there in three
weeks if he decides to do it we've seen
so many things with President Trump
being about ego and I mean I'm looking
at the daily news back page that says
caveman so no matter what happens from
here win or a loss for the president
certainly a short-term loss he blinked
this was a standoff between him and
Nancy Pelosi any blink and you know that
will frustrate him all weekend so you
wonder what what is the result of this
going into next week what does he
announce what does he say what does he
tweet we'll see but look he looks at
numbers like that disapproval 59% I was
57% the CBS poll and and that's you know
that's bad for him right now in the
short term but look for the most part
his basis today hasn't lost
right and as long as they somewhat hold
he thinks he's doing the right thing
meanwhile Nancy Pelosi has put the State
of the Union back on the table we don't
have a scheduled date for it yet but it
seems to be back again yeah she said
yesterday won't be well didn't entirely
rule out Tuesday the problem is it is a
big logistical hurdle to clear because
you're bringing all three branches of
government into the same room there's
security protocol there's some other
arrangements that they're made so if
it's not this Tuesday could be the
following Tuesday but don't be surprised
if suddenly Democrats turn around saying
why don't we wait until this three-week
period has passed because we don't want
to necessarily infect the negotiations
interesting that the shutdown news came
the same day that the Roger stone Oh
Friday was a miserable day at the White
House you take the airport slowdown
which was a result of this and the fact
of the President had to do what he did
look stones yet another person close to
the president tied up in this makes it
harder for them to continue making the
arguments that he has nothing to do with
it or knows nothing about it we'll see
where the evidence on this one goes but
it made pretty clear yesterday the
indictment did stone was talking to
WikiLeaks and WikiLeaks may have had
contact with the Russians and there was
somebody at Trump Tower the stone was in
contact with on a regular basis the saga
continues the president clearly didn't
want to take questions on that one no no
for the Democrats at this point now I
know they keep saying we're gonna wait
for the Miller Report Writer wait for
the Miller report what does this do for
them in that way already
they're waiting for them other report
and and and the sort of unanimity we've
seen on that say for a few members is
pretty remarkable but remember the
investigations continue this past week
the Oversight Committee announcing
they're gonna start looking into
questions about who got security
clearances that is the start of all
these investigations they promised to
look at all aspects of the
administration and and we will continue
to see examples of that in the coming
weeks new investigations and the
different aspects of the administration
and that's one way that they'll be able
to sort of release the valve a little
bit on that pressure from Democrats back
home to investigate the problem all
right Eddie
excuse me Eddie
always I open with you here on the Dan
family on a Saturday tomorrow morning on
Face the Nation here on CBS Margaret
Brennan's guests will include acting
White House chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
and Senator Susan Collins of Maine and
Joe Manchin of West Virginia